so are you still on OVO yeah yeah yeah
for you like uh I just saw Drake shout
you out in this interview where he's
with this random white woman in bed
you shut up Bobby
do we know where this this came from
there's industry plants and Hip-Hop I
feel like she's like an industry playing
on the media side because I'm like where
did this girl come from so you never see
interviews I've only seen the funny
Marco one oh it was like it was funny
Marco and then it was Drake and I was
like that escalated quickly like shout
out to her yeah that's did she follow
you no no no she didn't she did yes she
wasn't interested
try to set you up a lot no no no no no
no no
um are you are you living in the US you
live in Canada are you spent time or
what are you doing splend time
especially because right now I just
dropped my tape I did what I did oh no
go stream that but I live in Toronto
mostly right because my daughter is over
there also so like I just try to split
the time equally
like how's your daughter she's five oh
you got a little kindergartner but yeah
yeah yeah she's in Camp right now
enjoying her Camp time yeah yeah summer
camp and I just when I was there I was
dropping in an account every day and
then oh every time I drop her to these
things like the the cat people are so
excited to see me you know they're like
smiling yeah so she gets this different
type of she probably gets better
treatment yeah extra snacks at lunch
yeah even like at school sometimes
sometimes I don't think she likes it too
because I don't think she likes she
wants all the attention to she's a
little star girl too so like you know is
she aware that you're famous yeah yeah
yeah she's super aware does she have a
favorite Smiley song
um not really to be honest like she'll
sing them like she doesn't really like
I serve too much in it in my songs too
so I don't really played around her or
anything like that and like I don't
really play my music earlier so like I
and like when she hears my music
sometimes she'll be like that you're
swearing this this like I try not to
swear as much but I yeah
um where would you say like oh first of
all how long like did you start rapping
like how long has it been since you kind
of first started taking this serious so
probably like
seven years ago but that was when I
first started rapping and I was in a
group of three people it was three of us
and I was like I always say that's why
it's just funny because I was like the
least favorite in the group was because
I didn't rap they forced me to get on
the song Because I set up the studio
session for them because I'm like yo you
guys after that got expelled from the
English school in two months of being
there I'm like yo you guys are sick like
you guys keep freestyling the hood and I
see the potential in them I set up a
studio session and then they went they
did their first song yeah and I'm like
[__] I never even wrapped a day in my
life I don't know how to do I don't even
know any flaws nothing I did my first
song and that's how my flow came about
was it nothing I thought of nothing it
was this is your first song you
automatically yeah
I said it I didn't premeditated nothing
you know so
yeah that was my first song and then
from there we had we gained a little
traction and then we just kept going
dropping a song probably every three
months and then we all got arrested
together in a read and now we became
cool cues so that we couldn't make music
together so then where you became more
cool cues were like when let's say me
and you we got arrested you guys aren't
allowed to legally hang out yeah yeah
none of that we're on house for us and
then they stopped making music and I'm
like [__] up like my solo yeah I'm
like yo you guys are done and we can't
make music together someday imma just
try a thing like you know I'm gonna make
my songs by myself and I recorded videos
in my in my backyard yeah and I kept
going and then from there I had a I
stopped for a bit and then
I just decided to go serious at some
point in time you know what you guys get
rated for
um Trap House you know chop was a
running yeah booming make that [__] boom
brother